[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker filling in for dan obviously
i feel like i do this every monday after
the draft joined now by mike renner who
does an unbelievable job for pro
football focus a lot to get to as it
relates to the draft although mike i got
to start which is always great by the
way for the people listening on fox
portrait i gotta start with mike's
sweatshirt
because i'm looking at my sweatshirt
this is a key question it like were you
painting over the weekend is that real
paint or is that like are you just
fashionable and that's the thing now is
you wear a sweatshirt that makes it look
like you were painting it was purchased
with said paint already on i am not a
handyman by any means so this was it was
a fashion statement am i in so that's
like the style mike how old are you yes
i am 32 years old i just turned 32. okay
because i feel like
if that's the style
then man i am out of style that's
amazing so you went to the store and
you're like i could get the fake paint
sweatshirt or the non-painted sweatshirt
and you went with the fake paint
sweatshirt
correct it's gotten a lot of love
actually it's a very polarizing piece
but it's very comfortable it's one of my
faves should we be asking mike for his
opinion on anything else for the rest of
this segment yes seton i just feel the
need i like his sweatshirt
i think it looks good
it looks awesome
it looks like you know what it looks
like my buddy in college who was a
roofer and like he everything he wore
like had like paint on it and stuff like
you look like a man's man mike you don't
look like a guy that sits in an office
and evaluates tape all day
well that's what i'm going for i want to
surprise people with that
all right so a lot to get into here um
let's start with
draft grades because i was saying
earlier
not a big fan of the people that say you
can't do draft grades for three years
dude how do you look at it is it just
the players they got is it the strategy
is it you know how well they did with
what they had to work with how do you
guys evaluate over a pro football focus
yes it's what you had to work with
because we actually went you go back and
look at like draft grades and the teams
that had two first-round picks
like no one gets lower than a b-plus in
those it's like oh yeah they got they
got a bunch of really good players like
of course they were going to they had
two first-round picks so for us like we
gave the giants a lower grade then
probably i think we gave them the lowest
grade of anyone because five and seven
were always going to be good players you
know like five and seven were no-brainer
picks so you can't give them credit for
that they had picks five and seven
because they sucked last year so to me
the draft rate has to be the decisions
that went into the picks so if you know
if you didn't have a top hundred pick
you could still get an a if they were
good decisions that you made so that's
how we do our draft grades at pfff it's
such a great point because i have not
seen the jets get anything other than a
plus anywhere they had three first round
picks and four of the first 36 like i
mean if they didn't get
and they got name guys that were ranked
number one of their position or whatever
if they didn't get good players and they
should fail
yeah exactly and that's too much of
draft analysis you got to actually
dig into these picks okay so then i was
saying this earlier we just mentioned
the tyrant matthew news with the new
orleans saints looks like he's going to
sign there
but in terms of what they had to work
with do you take into account how much
like the saints
gave up to get chris olavey like the
trade with the eagles then the trade
with the
commanders it's like five or six picks
for chris o'lave mike
yes we definitely took that's all we
gave him a c plus which is probably one
of the lower people out there giving
grades but it was
this year's first round pick
two third round picks this year fourth
round pick next year's first round pick
and a 2024 second round pick that is
what it cost you for one chris o'lava
and that's not even like i love crystal
lava i think he's going to be a great
player and perfect for that offense but
there are
there have been safe quote unquote safe
picks who have not worked out in the nfl
so to be the hat give up that much for
one guy
is to me
that's you can't give that a good grade
because of so many opportunity costs
missed
is there a team that we're not talking
about that you really liked or really
didn't like it seems like everybody's
talking about the same teams give me
someone that you guys really liked or
really didn't like that maybe isn't
getting as much attention
that's a good i i really like the
cowboys draft i don't think a lot of
people have really loved it you know
jerry jones had to go out and show his
draft board to justify their first round
but i think they got three starters at
three very valuable positions at tackle
edge rusher and wide receiver with their
first three pick and then they had one
of the best day threes of anyone i think
their fifth round picks all have a role
on this roster and damon clark in the
fifth round
he's obviously not going to play as a
rookie with the neck fuse and surgery
but if he doesn't have that if you can
just you know throw that first
throughout the season which you do for a
lot of rookies anyways
he's a top you know 70 player in this
class at the linebacker position that
they got at 176 so i think the cowboys
had a very underratedly good draft
talking with mike renner he's the lead
draft analyst for pro football focus and
co-host of tailgate which sounds amazing
sounds like a show i should be on
speaking of beer and food uh let's get
into some of these quarterbacks cause
i'm really curious mike
how much work you do work in the off
season right like you evaluate the kids
coming into the year
a lot of people i really respect
had a first round grade on sam howell
coming into the year
he went in the fifth round mike
wasn't injured how does that happen how
do you guys and maybe you're going to
tell me you didn't but how do you
watch the video of him in freshman and
sophomore year
say he's a first round pick
he plays a whole season
and then he's a fifth round pick how
does that happen
because it wasn't he didn't fall there
because of this tape now the tape wasn't
good this year but even still it was not
fifth round tape he fell there because
of his interviews from all that i've
heard was not good on a white board was
not good with protections blitz
recognition those sort of things just
did not impress anyone and
i think a lot of these quarterbacks fell
just because there weren't a lot of
landing spots you know there weren't
many teams really if you're drafting a
guy with a top 50 pick you're putting
them in that start a conversation or at
least to challenge your starter and no
one was really really willing to do that
and so when you have a guy who's as far
behind the learning curve as sam howell
was reportedly what i've heard i just
think teams were willing to go elsewhere
even though that like the sophomore tape
was great like it was first round tape
and that was you know none of these
other guys were putting up near what he
did as a true sophomore at north
carolina so
i i still was a fan of his i would have
taken him before
you know any of those guys
a lot of those guys that went in the
third round to where i think the
washington commanders where they got
them have to be really really happy
that's really interesting mike i had not
heard that about sam howell on the
interview process i did see
some reports of some concerns about
erratic behavior from matt corral i
think ian rappaport said that
during the draft what about malik willis
i mean i you know these are the times
where i almost feel like mike we're
being lied to i mean
so many people said oh the talent the
upside you know top 10 pick top 20 pick
then he doesn't go till the third round
was he was that a team meeting thing as
well or were we lied to like how does
that happen
that one
is the one i can't explain i think he's
he is talk like there's there's no doubt
about it you flip on his tape for five
five plays and you'll see a cannon of an
arm you'll see elite rushing ability
he's probably the second best runner at
the quarterback position in the nfl
right now
and
the biggest thing with him though is the
learning curve is just literally the
offense he played in is not going to
have anything to do with the offense he
plays at the nfl just nothing similar
whatsoever they're at liberty so
the learning curve so if you're taking
them high you're probably waiting two to
three years for him to even see the
football field and then the offense he's
going to have to run so it's not like
jalen hurts in that manner who you know
is going to be able to hit the field
quickly despite maybe having limited
physical tools who's also you know
runner at the position but then once he
does hit the league once he does start
the offense he's going to run is going
to look like maybe a couple offenses
around the nfl it's going to look like
what the ravens do with lamar jackson
because if you're not taking advantage
of that you're doing it wrong he can't
just come in and say you're
you know it's even the titans where he
went and do the exact same thing you're
going to do with ryan tannehill it's
going to have to be unique to him and
not a lot of teams are willing to do
that for a backup have a special package
of plays have a special offense just for
their backup to come in so i think that
was the biggest if i'm gonna pinpoint
any reason he fell it would be that
mike last one what about the 2023 draft
because i saw where you just dropped
your mock draft which by the way some
people get real upset about i love it i
think it's amazing people you can't do
that it's way too early it ruins kids
dreams it ruins everything like again
another person i don't want to invite to
my beer pong tournament ever is that
person but you just released your 2023
mock draft which is obviously very early
what who stands out to you what stands
out to you about the draft in general
and then what quarterbacks are you
pretty confident will go in round one
yeah i hate the people that think i'm
hyping these guys up too much by putting
them in the first round as if like all
these guys haven't had their ego stroke
they haven't been five-star recruits
with their ego strokes if they're like
16 years old i think they i think
they've had enough by now that one more
mock draft isn't going to push them over
the edge but
i will say the quarterback class is
better next year and i think that played
a factor in a lot of these runs whether
it was the seahawks
passing on quarterback whether it was
the falcons waiting till the third round
the lions like some of these teams that
were should have everyone thought would
be in the mix
i think next year is going to be the
year they go up and get their
quarterbacks because uh you know with
multiple first-rounders some of those
teams have the firepower to go up and
get one so it's a good quarterback class
and i really like this defensive tackle
class after some weak dt classes the
last two years we got some studs coming
in 2023.
jalen carter from georgia highest pass
rushing grade of any georgia defender
last year with gian carter loaded line
that you saw where we see three guys go
drafted first round from that defensive
line best ones still at georgia right
now and a guy named jacqueline roy at
lsu defensive tackle like there is some
defensive tackle talent that
is much needed in the nfl today
check him out pro football focus lead
draft analyst co-host to tailgate mike
renner mike thanks so much for the time
for sure thanks for having me ross
that was a groundbreaking interview
discussing whether or not you should buy
a sweatshirt that already has paint
stains on it